muchos republicanos siguen acudiendo a
las urnas por él soy republicana porque
quiero que comiencen a dirigir este país
como un negocio como liso Trump de
acuerdo pónganos de nuevo en marcha por
favor Aunque algunos ya no lo tienen tan
claro
republicana soy 100% republicana porque
amo este país No importa quién sea el
presidente Para mí Trump amo a Trump
pero voto más para salvar este país
el ex presidente Mientras tanto se ha
gustado en la campaña de las elecciones
de medio término muy participativo y
realizando una de sus aficiones
favoritas atacar al presidente Joe biden
él es un enemigo del Estado quieren
saber la verdad el enemigo del estado es
él y el grupo que lo controla
pero no deja de poner su mirada en las
elecciones de 2024
[Aplausos]
voy a hacer un gran anuncio el martes 15
de noviembre en mara lago en Palm Beach
Florida
[Música]
y Es que además de luchar contra los
demócratas Trump también Libra su propia
guerra interna en el seno de los
republicanos y en plena campaña se ha
inventado un apodo despectivo incluso
para su principal rival el gobernador de
Florida ron de santys
estamos ganando grande grande en la
nominación del partido republicano como
no lo ha hecho nadie antes vamos a ver
aquí está Trump en 71 ron de
sanctimonius en un 10%
de santis no suele rendir reverencia a
Trump ya estás haciendo mítines de
campaña como un presidenciable ya
recaudado 200 millones de dólares para
su candidatura y se ha negado a
reconocer que buscará reelegirse como
gobernador está aprovechando la
coyuntura con un Donald Trump con
investigaciones judiciales por
documentos secretos encontrados en su
residencia de Florida además de la que
se lleva a cabo por su influencia en el
asalto al Capitolio del 6 de enero de
2021 cuando se negó a reconocer los
resultados que dieron la presidencia su
rival joeyden esto ha dividido al
partido republicano con voces que
cuestionan las constantes polémicas del
expresidente